الآن، بعد مرور 4 أشهر على هجوم حماس الوحشي
على إسرائيل، أُجبر 1.3 مليون فلسطيني في
غزة على النزوح إلى
مدينة رفح الجنوبية بينما كان جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
يقصف غزة، والآن تضع إسرائيل
أنظارها على تلك المدينة المكتظة
بالمرحلة التالية من خططها للمحاولة.
للقضاء على حماس، يقول القائد الأعلى للجيش الإسرائيلي
هناك إنه لا توجد حاليًا خطة معمول بها
لتقليل عدد القتلى بين المدنيين، لكنه
سيعمل على مثل هذه الخطة إذا وعندما
يتلقى أوامر بدخول رفح،
وبينما يبدو أن القتال في غزة
يتصاعد.
يحاول أنتوني بلينكين التوسط لوقف
إطلاق النار واتفاق الرهائن الذي
رفضته إسرائيل للتو بعد
المقترحات الأخيرة من كاماس، دعونا نحضر
وزير الدفاع السابق في عهد دونالد ترامب،
مارك إسبير، إنها أول
مقابلة له على الإطلاق في دوره الجديد كمذيع
شؤون عالمية في شبكة سي إن إن.  محلل أه،
يعمل أيضًا في مجلس الإدارة أو
كمستشار استراتيجي لعدد قليل من
الشركات ذات الصلة بالفضاء والدفاع، سكرتير إسبر،
مرحبًا بك في CNN، يسعدني رسميًا
تواجدك
هنا، شكرًا جيك، يسعدني أن أكون معك، وكذلك
العلاقة الطويلة الأمد بيننا وبين إسرائيل بشكل أساسي و  لقد
تغيرت بشكل لا رجعة فيه خلال الأشهر الأربعة الماضية،
هل تعتقد
أنني لا أعتقد ذلك، لذلك أعتقد أن
الروابط الثقافية التاريخية وغيرها
عميقة جدًا وطويلة الأمد بحيث لا يمكن
تغييرها بشكل أساسي، أعلم
بوضوح أن هناك تغييرًا في العلاقة
بين واشنطن وتل
أبيب  أه وعلى الأخص مع bbnet
وياهو وحكومته اليمينية المتطرفة،
أعتقد أن هذا هو التغيير وبالطبع
سيستمر هذا في التطور مع استمرار
هذا الصراع
وحكومته ليست مجرد يمينية متطرفة
أعني أنه أه إذا كان المتعصبان الدينيان الفاريان
المتعصبون سموتريتش وبن جافيير
إذا قاموا برحلة
سيأخذون معهم نظريًا 14 مقعدًا،
وذلك وستسقط حكومة ياهو،
لذلك لا يمكنه تنفيرهم بأي
شكل من الأشكال، ولديهم وجهات نظر متطرفة حقًا
بشأن آراء الفلسطينيين العنصرية حول
الضفة الغربية وقطاع غزة، هل هناك أي سلام ممكن
في المنطقة مع هذه
الحكومة الإسرائيلية وهؤلاء الأشخاص فيها،
نعم، انظر، أنت على حق، جيك، لديك
هؤلاء الأعضاء وغيرهم ممن يريدون
إعادة احتلال غزة والذين يريدون دفع
سكان غزة الفلسطينيين في غزة إلى
مصر وأماكن أخرى
وإعادة المستوطنين اليهود مرة أخرى، لذا فهذا ليس
شيئًا ممكنًا. أعتقد أن
الطيف الأوسع للسياسة الإسرائيلية
لا يريد إعادة احتلال غزة، لكنهم
يريدون وضعًا دفاعيًا أفضل
وبالطبع عليك التعامل
معه.  ما هي النتيجة النهائية التي ما زلنا
لا نعرفها؟ لدينا بعض الخطط وبعض الأفكار
ولكن لديك حل الدولتين
الذي يظل هناك على الأرجح أفضل حل
ممكن على افتراض أن لديك
سلطة فلسطينية تم إصلاحها أو تجديدها ولكن انظر، أعتقد أن
السياسة  داخلية لأه إسرائيل داخل
حكومته هي ما يدفع بي بي
نتنياهو الآن لاتخاذ هذه
المواقف المتشددة فيما يتعلق على سبيل المثال
بالمقترح الأخير أه الذي عاد من
حماس وما هي احتمالية التوصل إلى صفقة
وأريد أن أنتقل أيضا إلى
الأخبار العاجلة  من العراق، الغارة الأمريكية بطائرة بدون طيار في
بغداد، يقول رجل القيادة المركزية أن
قائد حزب الله المسؤول عن
مهاجمة القوات الأمريكية في المنطقة
قُتل عند النظر إلى الفيديو،
تبدو الضربة دقيقة للغاية أم تشرح
التخطيط وجمع المعلومات الاستخبارية التي
تدخل في ضربة مثل
هذا نعم حسنًا بالطبع نحن
نبذل جهودًا كبيرة أه في وزارة الدفاع
والإنترنت ومجتمع الاستخبارات
لتعقب قادة هذه
المجموعات المختلفة وهناك الكثير منهم هناك
هذه أه
مجموعات الميليشيات الشيعية المدعومة من إيران وتريد
تتبعهم  مكان تواجدهم الذي تريد معرفة
الأشخاص الذين يلتقون به، وتريد محاولة
اعتراض الاتصالات
لفهم ما يفعلونه، لذا انظر إلى أنه يتم
تتبعه بعناية شديدة، وأعتقد أن هذا
أمر جيد أنهم قاموا
باستهداف جيد ومن الجيد قتل أه
قادة هذه الجماعات ولكن يبدو أن
أفضل ما ستفعلونه هو تعطيل
وإضعاف قدراتهم إذا كنتم
تريدون الردع حقًا، وقد قلت هذا قبل أن يتعين عليكم
ملاحقة الأشياء التي
تقدرها إيران وبالنسبة لإيران فإن هذه المجموعات الوكيلة
قابلة للاستهلاك  لقد كانوا على هذا منذ
40 عامًا وهم يمولونهم ويسلحونهم
ويدربونهم أه لكن كما تعلمون الحديث
الأسبوع الماضي عن رد قوي أه على
إيران بناءً على مقتل
الجنود الأمريكيين الثلاثة هو
نوع من تركني  خيبة الأمل قليلاً
فيما يتعلق بما رأيناه حتى الآن
وما أعتقد أنه سوف يردع الإيرانيين أو لا يردعهم عن المضي
قدمًا، لقد تعرضنا بالفعل
لهجومين أو ثلاثة من مجموعات الميليشيات منذ
الهجوم الـ 85 المستهدف يوم الجمعة الماضي من قبل القوات الأمريكية